my fellow citizen
if you are hearing this tape then the
world as we knew it has finished
the sky has broken the ground heaves
with the [ __ ] of terrible feet
and all the horror and madness from the
dark corners of the world has broken
free to exact its vengeance on the world
of man
those who sought to contain them are
killed or scattered
and we soon learned that to attempt to
fight these creatures
is almost invariably to face one's death
countless billions have been slaughtered
in their attempt to save their endless
appetite for death
and there is nothing was nothing we
could do to stop them
evil has raised its bloody flag upon all
nations of the world
and crowned its unholy victory to the
broken sky
yes this is the end
but there is a new hope
welcome to on london
a city of the survivors a city
of the free together fellow citizen
we will wait and prepare for the new
beginning
the grand new world that is soon to come
let the world above burn we will endure
let the monsters have their world we
will prepare
and let the ground tremble with a new
armageddon
as evil consumes itself for i tell you
citizen
upon the day of the ruination of man
their
insatiable appetites will turn them
against one another in their
endless lust for death we will wait
and i tell you citizen that there will
be a new morning
and you will emerge from on london and
stand
blinking in the sun as our children play
and laugh in the bones of horrors long
dead
and you will walk hand in hand
to the sea our faces skywards
as the rising sun ushers in the new age
of man
and you will gather citizen at my feet
as i summon on london from its rest and
it shall burst
phoenix-like from the ashes of the old
and on that day citizen there shall be a
new
order as we raise the union flag over
the
entire world
i welcome you to on london
[Music]
the last city and the first
you